Dodgers beat the Rays in Tampa 7-3
Clayton Kershaw pitched into the seventh
inning allowed two earned runs
Cody Bellinger our next guest went 1 for
3 with 2 walks he's currently batting
over 400 with 17 home runs and he joins
us now
good morning Cody how are you I'm good
how are you good what is the normal
routine when you're on the road so like
let's say you're at the hotel what do
you do all day
ah usually wake up around 11:00 I forgot
last time I listened to your show I
forgot about the East Coast time change
I woke up at like 12:45 so I apologize
for that
but on the road you have BP at like 5 so
you get at the field around 1 o'clock
and other than that I usually walk to
Starbucks and there's one there and just
lay in bed until until the bus time is
here you watch TV yeah I watch TV and
what do you want we usually ESPN ok
yeah that's about it what happens when
you come on
on ESPN when you're watching I watch in
terms of volume well you should yeah you
should I'd be that blasted in the hotel
but so when your highlight comes up you
just want to hear what they're saying
yeah I don't think that it's pretty
weird seeing myself on on the highlights
on the highlight reel but yeah usually
just you know you're watching and
baseball highlights come on and then you
know there you are on the TV so it's
pretty cool
who did you grow up as a fan of the
Yankees just because my dad was on the
team so I was in New York living there
and and gone to those games what's the
earliest member memory you have of going
to those games to be honest it's kind of
weird I remember my dad in the minor
leagues more because I was actually bad
blowing for him and I was getting the
bats so I have some more memories of
that I don't remember unfortunately much
of
New York in the clubhouse and everything
about that Derek Jeter did you aspire to
be Derek do you didn't aspire to be dad
you sparred to be Derek Jeter absolutely
sorry Zack he's a legend so I think I
think it was it was awesome getting to
know him and talk to him what did you
ask him back in the day you had no idea
but I'm out in Miami last year and got
up a little bit and it's it's pretty
cool to have conversations with him just
because of the kind of player he was
explain to the audience your job as a
rookie on the team what did they make
you do I think it's kind of changed from
maybe way back in the day I think bait
the rookies used to have it a little
worse but every road trip I'd have to
bring a trash bag full of beer and hand
it out on the bus what else
I had to encounter or we can Chicago we
had to dress up
Halloween costumes I was uh yeah I was
Elvis Presley we had to walk the walk
the streets and our costumes and that's
about it though we didn't have anything
anything like that that was too crazy
did you get yelled out yeah we had a
group of like 12 so it was just a bunch
of people watching us saying what the
hell is going on what's Halloween who
runs the Dodger Clubhouse like the music
you know who is the if there's a judge
and jury you know who who is the judge
I'd say combination of Kershaw and
Justin Turner and kenley jansen just the
guys that have been there for years and
years I wouldn't fight kenley jansen for
a million bucks
he's really big I when I saw him at the
all-star game and I walked by I go he's
he's a close he could have been a tight
end in the NFL but he was a catcher but
still even as a catcher that's that's
big yeah absolutely he's for sure the
biggest dude in that cave if I said you
had to face Janssen or ker
Shaw who do you want Dan and they're in
their primes
none of them for one at-bat yeah I'm
thinking can we just kiss either right
II think it's gonna be a little harder
to face Kershaw lefty/lefty matchup do
you get to face these guys at all either
their inner squad or even spring
training simulated games have you faced
kershaun before never faced Kershaw and
I say Kenley I think once in spring
training in 2016 or 17 yeah I think I've
actually faced him a few times I say
something in the spring - he's Kodi
Bellinger the native of Chandler Arizona
and currently batting over 400 how how
many times are you reminded that you're
batting over 400 every day to be honest
whether it's social media or just the
media come up to talk to me but it's
definitely cool but I think the most
important thing is just like trying to
block that stuff out every single day
but you talk to and I've had
conversations with Tony Gwynn and George
Brett and Rod Carew and you know that
that all they wanted to do is they
wanted to hit the ball hard they wanted
to just if they hit the ball hard then
they were fine with it it's when they
started to miss pitches or they didn't
look good look comfortable that's when
they started to worry your philosophy
going to the plate is what ah that's it
I mean I I think obviously everyone move
through this and that's the hardest part
but like timing is everything at the
plate and when you're playing every
single day I think the hardest thing to
do is to lock it in like mentally every
single like that
tend to give it that way but I think you
just go to the plate and like force
yourself to lock it in you're gonna give
yourself that little more advantage but
uh yeah I think the the biggest key is
just starting to hit the ball hard and
doesn't matter where it goes how you hit
it just try to make good contact once
the last time you tried to hit a home
run
yes sir sure tried this year I think
there's like certain at-bats and certain
pictures right now I'm feeling good I'm
gonna try to go deep here I don't I
don't remember the last time but I
definitely had those thoughts this year
how many pitchers do you think tip their
pitches man with video now oh it's there
this could be a lot but it's so like
minimal that like if you were to look at
it I think that it could mess you up
okay but no names no names here but
when's the last time somebody said hey
when he goes when he puts the ball in
his glove that way or the glove dips
down then he's going breaking ball like
when's last night recently no names no
date for sure recently how did you do ah
let's see I don't I didn't use it I
don't I think that messes with my head a
little bit I have tried it before and
kind of overthink it and just get just
me out of my game but I know some people
that love obviously it helps knowing
what pitch is coming but yeah sometimes
it messes me more than it helps what do
people say to you on the streets in Los
Angeles they see you socially they say
I'm a huge soccer fan and and can I take
a picture I think that's about it I mean
sometimes there's ol just say there
Dodger fans and give me a handshake and
walk away and yeah Los Angeles cool man
there's there's a bunch of Dodger fans
everywhere so it's pretty cool walking
the streets and getting recognized out
there
give me the celebrity who maybe took
your breath away or you're a little
tongue-tied when you met him at a Dodger
game
I met Kobe Bryant last year in the
locker no boy yeah I was in the video
room met him and I literally was almost
speechless I felt like an idiot I
couldn't like it's the right words out
of my mouth though that was for sure the
coolest moment or the coolest first time
it did you give him something or did you
ask for something uh he actually signed
a pair of shoes for me the
a year before that I got some type of
shoes from fell B and then had him sign
them and I think I gave him a Jersey
like to say thanks you know I don't even
know if he signed as there's even you
wouldn't want to give up one of your
bats though / Kobe / sure oh it gave up
to bat how much do you love your bat ah
yeah I do I've actually had the same
thought the same bad with the same model
since 2016 so I'm pretty superstitious
in that aspect of like how it feels in
my hands and I like changing the kind of
that that I ask I'm looking at you at
the plate and I know that this is a
little too geeky but 2017 bat is flat at
address 2018 more upright and then this
year you're back to being flat so what's
gonna so what why the change the change
in 18 I think I was struggling a little
bit and I wanted to I was just like it
was a I was trying to like find
something that day that's gonna help me
get a hit and when you're in that
mindset you start changing things and
ultimately like not sticking with your
plan that's been successful so this
offseason we got new hitting coaches and
they've been incredible so I went back
to whiles having success and kind of
made it into my own swing again before I
let you go I was curious about this on
when you run with Jimmy Kimmel I believe
last year you said that you drive a or
you have a scooter and there's a reason
why you have a scooter and not a car
what is that reason well the first
reason was it was like two minutes your
eyes and like a 10 minute walk and the
card have to go down three levels to get
it and it's also a big truck so it's
like trying to park that thing in a
little parking lot in Los Angeles is not
easy so ended up buying the scooter and
just take it into the restaurant and
park it next to me if I get sued or take
it out and just makes things a little
easier out there can you parallel park
I couldn't and then I actually moved out
of my house bought a place in the only
way to park was to parallel park so I
had to learn so I actually can tell my
parallel park now now your parents must
be so proud that you know and your
batting it what's your dad say about
your batting average uh he just you know
tells me to go out there and keep
getting asti he's like she he
understands my swing he like knows took
my hands are getting higher or lower and
if they are I'll agree with them but
sometimes I did it on purpose like
saying this feels good right now and but
yeah he's just my number one Supporter
and wants me to do great every single
day you can all you have to do is say to
your dad hey I'm batting twice your
batting average that you had in 1999 dad
you you've added 200 in 1999 I'm hitting
400 you got three rings though you can
he can pull that on me does he pull the
Rings out uh here and there I've seen
him we usually keep him locked away but
uh yeah he's for sure brought him out
there special rings are pretty
incredible would be honest I like it a
little dad smack talk don't teach him
hey great to talk to you glad to have
you on and good luck again who you
facing tonight
the pitcher yeah I honestly I don't even
know they they do the opener if you
heard about the opener so oh yeah guy
goes through innings and then and then
the starter will come out so I honestly
don't don't know for sure we'll figure
that out when I get there
if you Homer tonight you'd be nice to
get a shout out after the game for the
show I mean you know all right
like the interview puts you in a great
mood and you know like can't help but
thank the Dan Patrick show for putting
me in this place absolutely all for sure
do that thank you that's right
appreciate that's Cody Bellinger right
there yeah you know sometimes that
they'll hit a home run for a sick child
this is really for a sick program that
just lost this sports Emmys like you
know we're sort of a make-a-wish TV show
here for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]